hay días que es muy fácil despertar les
ha tocado te levantas de buenas todo
fluye de maravilla pero hay otros días
que cuesta mucho trabajo despertar
a mí me pasó en ocasión en la época de
la p
antes de la pandemia
me tocó pues
despertar que me costó camino al trabajo
se me ocurre la extraordinaria idea de
llegar por un cafecito
y me estaciono me bajo pero lo que me
sucede y lo que te quiero platicar es
algo que probablemente te ha sucedido
la persona que me atendió lo hizo con
una actitud nefasta
levante la mano a quien lo han atendido
con esto su nefasta
bueno déjenme contarles que hasta me
puso de malas no aparte eran la época
antes de la pandemia donde no había
cubrebocas pues no había sonrisa en la
persona que me atendió
confieso que me moleste pero pues me
resigné y pueda esperar mi café no y
mientras me entregaba mi café
pensaba a lo mejor es una maestra de la
paciencia dios la trajo al mundo
enseñarme a ser más paciente y andaba yo
haciéndome el típico coco wash y no pero
lo que me sucedió a continuación fue
algo realmente extraordinario la segunda
persona que me entregó el café me lo
hice una forma fantástica estaba de
buenas me sonrió aparte pues te dicen
por tu nombre no entonces josemaría no
pasó me entregan mi café pero eran siete
y media la mañana y el tren a actitud
extraordinaria me dieron ganas de
preguntarle qué desayunaste no para
desayunar lo mismo me subo a mi coche
voy camino a mi trabajo y ahí es donde
inicia este momento confieso que seguí
estaba un poco reflexivo
como es posible que dos personas el
mismo día a la misma hora y en el mismo
lugar puedan tener actitudes tan
diferentes y probablemente con el mismo
sueldo
buenas noches damas y caballeros mi
nombre es josé maría playa y por poco
más de una década me he desarrollado y
me especializado en atender el
desarrollo humano fundé una empresa
donde hemos impactado a más de 12 mil
personas en más de 100 organizaciones en
todo el país y a lo largo de este tiempo
he observado que los líderes que
transforman positivamente su entorno
hacen cinco cosas desarrollaron cinco
virtudes y el día de hoy estoy que me
gana la emoción de compartir se los
porque son cosas muy simples son
virtudes que todos podemos desarrollar
porque no tiene nada que ver nuestra
capacidad intelectual aquí no es a
diosito no pasó por el hard rock hotel
pony modo no tiene que ver con nuestra
capacidad de decidir y de tomar acción
porque el liderazgo eso es el liderazgo
es una decisión no es un rol o un rango
es una decisión
a este modelo lo he llamado penta
liderazgo y está conformado de cinco
vértices y un común denominador y si me
permiten sería un honor para mí
presentarse los la primera vértice del
penta liderazgo es exemplu
qué significa ejemplo por supuesto quién
sepa latín significa ejemplo en latín
pero qué significa realmente tener
exemplu
significa que los líderes que
transforman positivamente su entorno
saben que muchas veces las
circunstancias no las elegimos pero
siempre podemos elegir nuestra actitud
ante lo que nos sucede tener exemplu es
predicar con el ejemplo
quieres que tu equipo de trabajo llegue
puntual es el primero en llegar quieres
que tus hijos
crezcan tiene unas personas educadas
conviértete en la persona más cordial
que conoces el día de hoy quiero hacerte
un llamado porque estoy seguro que todo
lo que vamos a platicarles de hoy lo
puedes desarrollar en todas las áreas de
tu vida y es que el penta liderazgo esa
es la magia de el tener exemplu es vivir
en un país
donde menos personas den su opinión y
más prediquen con su ejemplo
porque al final de cuentas hay dos tipos
de personas las que suman o las que
restan
si hubiera un test no imagínense un test
de esas revistas que nos gusta ver en la
sala de espera de los doctores y fueran
descubre qué tipo de persona eres en una
sola pregunta la pregunta sería muy
sencilla sería después de que alguien
estuvo contigo le sumas tele restante le
inspiraste el estrés hazte es más
pregúntate qué crees que dirían las
personas con las que interactúan hasta
el día de hoy de ti
y es que el sex en pluma
porque te digo algo muchas veces las
personas podrán olvidar lo que les
dijiste pero nunca olvidarán como la
asiste sentir
nunca sabes a quién podrá estar
inspirando eso es ejemplo
la segunda vértice del penta liderazgo
le ha denominado
sensibilidad empática alguien escuchado
la frase que le empatía es ponerte en
los zapatos del otro sí pues realmente
realmente la sensibilidad empática es
muy poderosa pero lo que lo hace muy
poderosa
es que apliquemos la sensibilidad de
forma correcta
como lo podemos hacer como podemos
hacerlo de forma correcta
déjenme contarles una historia
tengo un amigo que tiene cuatro hijos
está casado se llama luis no le hago
decir su apellido por capaz que lo
conocen no pero sigue viviendo en la
avenida lópez mateos número 243 para
entonces
llegó un día a saludar a mi amigo luís
tiene cuatro hijos
yo no tengo hijos no estoy casado bueno
ya estoy comprometido
y por aquí está
bueno
llegó y quiero quien ya tiene más de 23
hijos se imaginará a la escena no abro
la abre la puerta luis y la escena es
dos peleándose de un lado y otro muy
interactivo el otro lado y el en brazos
me abre la puerta como puede
yo entro y queriendo ser empático le
digo louis en que te ayudo y el muy
educado me dice no gracias y es que ahí
está el problema cuando queremos ser
empáticos ahí está el problema que
queremos ponernos en los zapatos del
otro cuando la situación es muy
diferente no estamos en el mismo barco
estamos tal vez en el mismo océano pero
no en el mismo barco
y ahí es no está el tema su
subconsciente pensó josemaría tal vez ni
siquiera sabes cambiar pañales me
explico
como si podremos ser empáticos y aquí es
donde viene lo interesante de la
sensibilidad empática la próxima vez que
quieras ser empático con alguien
pregúntate qué está sintiendo no la
circunstancia que está sintiendo es que
hace toda la diferencia cuando quieres
ser empático con alguien
la tercera vértice del penta liderazgo
y es algo que hemos observado en las
personas que hacen la diferencia es la
motivación
que si suena un juego de palabras de
hecho no es un error de ortografía la
motivación cuáles son los motivos que te
llevan a querer hacer las cosas
los lideres pentagonales entendemos que
es nuestra única responsabilidad
motivarnos todos los días no le toca ni
a nuestros amigos ni a nuestros
familiares no le toca a los gobernantes
por supuesto nos toca a nosotros
los motivos que te llevan a la acción
cuáles son las razones que te lleva te
llevan a querer hacer las cosas
la próxima vez que esta es una situación
con la familia en el plano profesional y
quieras que a alguien
siga tu objetivo
pregúntate cuáles son las razones que
van a hacer que esta persona quiera
hacerlo porque es muy diferente hacer
que querer hacer
y ahí está el secreto de la motivación
el día de hoy todos nosotros podemos
aplicarla por el simple hecho de estar
aquí estamos motivando nos todos los
días como lo podemos hacer a través de
ponernos en modo motivación dedica por
lo menos el 1% de tu día a motivarte que
en un día son 14 puntos 4 minutos y lo
dicen muchos expertos todos los días
escuchar un podcast buscar déjame lo
pongo bien porque no se me caen entonces
ahí está
entonces
busquemos todos los días motivarnos
estoy seguro que hace la diferencia
porque nos mantiene más enfocados y
hablando de enfoque
quiero compartir con ustedes una de mis
favoritas
a ver no es porque tenga consentidas
pero es que realmente está me ha servido
mucho
le titulado reenfoque muchas veces los
seres humanos le damos
mucho peso a ciertas cosas
a veces vamos como disco rayado les ha
pasado algo así no te sucede un problema
en la mañana
te sucede un problema en la mañana y te
pones de malas y a la siguiente persona
que te encuentres que crees que me pasó
que crees que me hizo la de contabilidad
y sufro sufro sufro y sufre sufre sufro
no llega a media el mediodía llegas a tu
casa a comer amor que gracia me pasó
pues que sufre sufre sufro y todo el día
vamos como disco rayado reenfoque es
justamente darle su debido peso a las
cosas
porque ir como disco rayado es como si a
tu equipo de fútbol le metieran tres
goles y durante todo el día estás viendo
en cámara lenta los goles que te
metieron
y ahora vamos a verlo en cámara lenta y
ahora en este ángulo y es que así vamos
por la vida el reenfoque es muy
importante porque los seres humanos que
queremos lograr esos objetivos
necesitamos estar en nuestro día a día
bien enfocados
al fin la navaja
entonces como lo podemos hacer no hemos
observado ya lo que me encanta que es la
regla de los cinco minutos
si lo que el día de hoy te tiene enojado
o frustrado no va a importar en un año
no gastes más de cinco minutos enojado
por ella
si no me importa en un año no gastes más
de cinco minutos por ello
porque al final de cuentas no aceptar lo
que no nos gusta es lo que nos hace
sufrir no aceptar lo que no nos gusta es
lo que nos hace sufrir es una gran frase
y muy cierta por cierto entonces darle
su debido peso a las cosas nos permite
fluir
logrando que lo que es importante para
ti realmente sea lo más importante
y por último quiero presentar con
ustedes
brújula no bruja brújula
los lideres pentagonales tienen claro
hacia dónde quieren ir y se desconectan
de la rutina para plantearse esos
objetivos no estoy diciendo que ya
tienen claro el como por qué el cómo se
va a ir dando conforme vayan pasando los
años
pero hay que tener clara la brújula
veamos por ejemplo el caso de los
marinos se guía mediante la brújula y la
brújula tiene dos elementos muy
importantes uno que es volteando todo el
tiempo hacia adelante estamos yendo
hacia atrás y estás volteando hacia
arriba hacia las estrellas
queridos
fellowes colegas del excel
piensan en grande
piensen en una brújula inmensa que dé
miedo
porque estoy seguro cuando te planteas
el que el como sea verdad no
y habiendo explicado este modelo
podrás preguntarte no oye entonces qué
forma el pentágono josemaría no pues
para misma lista no la lista de las
cinco cosas que es lo que realmente hace
que se forme un pentágono y es que cada
una de éstas tiene un común denominador
un común denominador
que no tendría sentido si no ponemos en
el centro de nuestras acciones a la
persona
porque poner en el centro de tus
decisiones
genuinamente el interés del otro hace
toda la diferencia
estamos llamados a servir estamos
llamados a ver cómo podemos el día de
hoy ayudar a otras personas a que tengan
un mejor día
y convertirnos en personas de
causalidades no de casualidades poner en
el centro a la persona hace toda la
diferencia
y hace que el pentágono cobre sentido
tenemos predicar con el ejemplo
tenemos aprender a usar de forma
correcta la empatía
tenemos encontrar los motivos que te
lleven a querer hacer las cosas
darle su debido peso a lo que nos sucede
y tener claro hacia dónde ir
si se fijan todo lo que acabo de decir
es muy simple porque el liderazgo es
simple
y todos lo podemos desarrollar
eso es el pentágono y estoy seguro que
este mundo sería un lugar mejor si
formamos a más líderes con corazón en
forma de pentágono hasta pronto
[Aplausos]